foreign
information retrieval and fully
homomorphic Grant computation show and
work with bake Highland and Eastern buck
so I'm going to tell you what these
things are in some detail in just a
little bit but before I do let me start
with a kind of a high level uh like the
informal just motivating example about
what this work is really all about
before we get into technical details and
the motivating example will some come
from something we do all the time just
Google search so here we have a user she
wants to search internet let's say she
wants to know what covet symptoms are so
she asks Google and gets a bunch of uh
search results
and so this talk is about privacy
um you know by
having Google see all of our search
queries throughout our lives it really
gives Google a very detailed and deeply
personal view into into our life and
maybe we shouldn't be comfortable with
that so can we do this while having uh
privacy and so what this would look like
is that the user would somehow encrypt
the search query before sending it to
Google under a key that the user has
and Google doesn't have the key so they
get the encrypted search query they have
no idea what the search term is but
nevertheless do you uh Google can still
kind of answer the search query with
some encrypted search results without
ever learning anything about the user
Square
so this sounds magical but we actually
for the last 15 years we have a magical
tool that solves this problem really
homework encryption it exactly lets you
do this and enables arbitrary
computation over encrypted data so
Google can take the encrypted search
query and perform the Google search
algorithm under the encryption and
produce the encrypted search results
without ever learning anything about the
query itself so amazing tool we should
be really happy about it
but I claim there's a major caveat here
there's a major issue with using morph
encryption even if we really optimize
the fhe and got it to be like really as
efficient as we could dream it would
still not be a good solution to this
problem and the reason is that in order
to use for the homework encryption to to
do this Google would need to read the
entire content of the internet uh to
answer every single search query and so
that's pretty much uh infeasible uh uh
right Google can't read the entire
internet for every single query
so uh that's a major caveat here and the
reason for this the reason that uh
Google has to do this is because
polygomorphic encryption operates in the
circuit model of computation you take
the computation write it down as a
circuit and if you wanted to write down
the circuit for Google search that
circuit would be as big as all the data
depends on which is the entire internet
so we're contain the entire internet
inside it and this is not just some like
kind of minor uh issue with our current
solutions to planomorph encryption this
is really baked in to how fully
homomorphic encryption works all it does
is it you know it can take two encrypted
bits and produce let's say the encrypted
and end of the bits and that's complete
for evaluating circuits so really like
fully homework encryption is tied to the
Circuit model
as it's currently defined and that's
kind of that's really the point of this
work we're going to take fully homework
encryption and Port it into the ram
model yeah
someone will only knows a bit about the
fhe
you need all of the data to also be
encrypted with the usual scheme
including somehow do it without being
indicated with the same key are you
talking about the like the the internet
data Simple Solution yeah can you do the
computation even though
yes yes you can kind of think of the
circuit like thinking of the internet as
part of the description of the circuit
you're evaluating on the query so you
would like hard code all the internet
data into the circuit
good and so that's the goal of this work
is to take fhe and Port it from the
circuit model into the ram model I'll
Define it somewhat generally like like
what this means in general later on in
the talk but for now for the special uh
example of Google search what that would
mean is that Google just would take the
internet content and pre-process it into
some data structure that will keep on
its side and then whenever it gets an
encrypted search query from a user it
can answer it with encrypted search
results just by looking up a few some
small number of locations in the data
structure without reading the entire
internet yeah they always reprocess the
internet business especially excellent
so that's exactly I was going to say and
already currently like Google has to
build an index of the internet so they
already have some data structure of them
so in some sense this data structure
would be specialized would be made for
answering encrypted queries not just
basic queries but at a high level it
doesn't look that different from what
Google currently does like the high
level solution concept is really the
same so wouldn't really change kind of
the the the the nature of how this works
Universal pre so this pre-processing is
done once for everyone and then any user
can come and search internet and
Google just looks at the free locations
yeah so this we process won't pick the
universe is deterministic function some
sort of deterministic kind of group of
us but I'll get into the details I'll
Define all these things so that was the
high level overview that's kind of if
you want to remember like if I'm in
summary of a discuss about that that's
it so now let's actually kind of roll up
the sleeves and be a technical yes which
was the necessary
yes yes we'll get there yeah absolutely
um so uh okay so we're gonna talk uh so
really I already told you a little bit
about uh fully homework encryption the
brand model it's that's the main goal of
the talk but I'm going to do a bit of a
bait and switch and most of the talk is
actually going to be about the simpler
primitive called double efficient
private information retrieval or DPR you
can think of the peer as a special case
of ram Fiji where the computation is
just that the user wants to access a
single entry in a database on the server
without revealing the server which entry
it is so it's a special case of ram Fiji
but it's actually like the heart of
ramaphision in the heart of ram
computations accessing data in a random
act accessing random having random
access to memory so once you solve the
first problem it's actually quite easy
easy using our techniques to also then
solve the second problem it's not
generic I don't know how to generically
go from the first to second but at least
with our techniques it's the first Palm
Is Real at the heart of the solution
with very strong proof like with
obfuscation yes yes
good
okay
so let me tell you about uh let me start
with defining this double efficient
private information of people let me
actually start with basic private
information people which is a problem
that's been around since uh the late 90s
so here we have a user that has an index
I and the user wants to retrieve the ith
entry of the database without revealing
the index to the server
okay so maybe for concreteness you can
think of the service Netflix is the
movie database and the user wants to
watch the if movie uh without revealing
it to the Netflix which movie she wants
to watch
so there's a trivial solution
the alphabet can be bigger
[Laughter]
all right so uh so there's a trivia
solution to this what's the previous
solution just Netflix like sends the
entire movie database to the user and
says okay pick your movie to watch
uh but that's not very efficient uh of
course downloading everything and we've
known for a long time that using
cryptography
um most kind of the standard the public
key crypto menu assumptions that we know
of give us a much better solution gives
us a non-trivial private information
retrieval where in fact you can get very
little communication like how they login
so the user and the server it's a
protocol and the the user learns the
output of the I quotation database uh
with very small communication without
reviewing that but just like before just
like within the uh with Google search
the random feature I was telling you
about before there's a caveat here which
is that although the communication
complex is small the server has to read
the entire database during the protocol
so the user wants to like watch one
movie Netflix would still have to read
the entire movie database to serve that
movie please and that makes this uh kind
of an efficient or or unpractical
medications and uh actually it's easy to
see already in this context that it's
inherent if uh if the server did not
read some portion of the database it
would know that the user's index is not
in that portion of the data which would
reveal something about the index
so it's actually necessary but it's the
rest of the reason or database but we
want to get around this anyway
so few notes and then I will try to get
around it and the idea of getting around
it so it's called double efficient
private information people to indicate
that also the server should be efficient
should not be the entire database and
the idea for how to how to do this is
that the several pre-process the
database ahead of time in an offline
phase before any user comes before
anybody wants to read any data
and the speed processing just converts a
database into some static data structure
that I'll uh that I'll denote by DB tell
that and this is done just once at the
very beginning uh it's a deterministic
function there's no C there's no
Randomness there's no secret Keys here
something the server can do on its own
and this preprocessing can run in linear
time scan that our database maybe even
slightly super linear and so the data
structure size might also be sideways
like the superlative
but once this is done once the database
is pre-processed the server now just
stores this pre-process data structure
and then any client can come and want to
read the IT location they can run an
efficient protocol where both the
communication of the protocol and the
server computation is small only
probably logarithm in the data size
which means that the server can only
read some small number of locations in
this pre-process data structure to run
the protocol
okay ideally just poly login
so uh so why is this problem hard well
the server only reads a small number of
locations in this uh data structure
during the protocol knows which location
it reads it sees which location has to
access during the protocol
and these locations just don't there's
too few of them they don't carry
information about the entire database so
if the server was unbounded it could
kind of figure out which locations of
the original data these uh these blue
locations get information about and
learn about the index that the client is
querying
now the hope is that because the service
computational bounded it cannot figure
that out
um so there's some hope to do this but
this kind of it has a lot of structure
and doesn't look like any of the
computation assumptions like factoring
or LW they're using crypto so it's kind
of not clear how you would use standard
assumptions to kind of create something
with the structure that's the difficulty
of the problem
really the difficulty is that the server
is the one who's usually you know you
have an outside person who's liking
quickly here's a sermons Queen so he
kind of she's nowhere exactly this is
like a totally determine the
pre-processant determination the server
knows like how the original data Maps
this database it's not clear where to
embed some computation assumptions
so let me tell you a little bit about uh
the prior work on this problem so this
this uh notion of double efficient peer
was introduced by by Cheyenne Malkin in
2000 so over 20 years ago and they had
some constructions in the multi-server
setting which I'm not talking about here
in the single serve setting which is the
focus of this talk uh they really had no
idea and they asked is this is this
possible and really at that time I think
that could have gone either way in fact
I think around 2010 or 2011 I spent some
time trying to prove a negative result
that this is impossible
um so it was really unclear which way
the answer would go uh and that changed
in 2017 there's uh two works that uh I
think finally gave the first evidence
that this is likely possible so what
they do they give heuristic
constructions of a relaxed variant not
quite the variant I told you about but a
relaxed variant that I'll call kid
double efficient peer so what does that
mean so in this variant the
pre-processing is not a deterministic
function the server does on its own it's
a secret key it's a secret it has secret
Randomness has to be done by some
external trusted party so some extra
party pre-processes this database of
secret Randomness and then publishes a
public key that clients can use to
access the data
okay so it's a relaxation but it still
kind of captures the heart of what you
want
uh and they showed how to do this uh
under heuristic assumptions so security
relied on a new assumption over permuted
read mother code
plus uh an additional heuristic use of
virtual black box office station was not
baby we can do it like Android
okay so quite strong to new assumptions
and so it was open whether you could get
rid of either of these first construct
Ankit that's the basic notion of the
efficient period under any assumptions
in heuristically or construct even the
key variant under better assumptions and
so in our work we kind of answer both of
these questions uh so we get the
standard the original notion
peer from standard assumption namely the
ring learning
let me just say a little about this
assumption so uh this is uh fairly well
studied assumptions it's it's as hard as
finding approximate short vectors
shortest vectors and ideal lattices in
the worst case and it's the basis of the
new nist standard for the next
generation of postponed public key
crypto so it's not just like us betting
on this assumption list is betting kind
of the US economy on this assumption as
well
uh for those who care we do have some
other alternate constructions under
related but like the different
assumptions named like proximate
greatest common divisor so gcd and true
and constant rank module
uh the construction uh actually has a
really nice uh structure it only
consists of two rounds and in the first
round the client can just set this send
the set of indices it wants the server
to look up in the data structure and
then the server just looks up with the
contents of the data structure and those
indices
and in terms of parameters uh for any
app for any constant Epsilon we have a
database of size capital N uh we have a
scheme where the pre-processing runs in
almost linear time of n to the one plus
Epsilon and the runtime and
communication complexity of the protocol
which is essentially the number of
locations in the data structure of the
service to look up is just poly login
yes
uh and furthermore we can actually also
make this construction updatable if the
server wants to update one bit of the
database it can do so by only updating a
small number of locations of the data
structures all then to the Epsilon
local updates are allowed as well
what do you pay for excellent
uh in the poly lock index in the
exponent of the poly lock
good uh so I want to quickly
about the availability so it's a bit
counterintuitive here is that you expect
it to be a good area code so how do you
update yes so it doesn't
answer uh um we uh I'm not going to talk
much about it I'll say a few words on
the latest
yeah how come it doesn't mean that you
can just
check for which index and to be
excellent places that only their
information so so uh uh good so yeah a
little bit comfortable but essentially
means that whatever's updated whenever
you make a query you always look at
those locations like that example
patients are updated are going to be
looked at every time when you as an
expert it's going to use it uses tools
okay I'll guess I'll say that use the
students from hierarchical or yes it's a
different model right now
the service of course it's thick but
it's updating it has to be stable but it
has no State Beyond updates like right
so there is no formal model that is
Kroger which is impossible
I don't I don't see one that makes sense
I mean the server has to be stateful
you're right for updates has to be
stable but that's that's inherent
because it's updating and yeah I think
it's a natural model
uh
so I want to just uh quickly compare to
some related Notions and cryptography
that address a similar problem
conceptualism or problem whether you
want to access remote data without
revealing what you're accessing namely
oblivious RAM and a more recent notion
of peer with client-side preprocessing
the main difference uh for both of these
Notions and what we do is that in these
Notions you need a separate linear time
preprocessing of the database for every
user that joins the system like every
time a new user wants to I don't know do
Google search Google would need to
pre-process the internet for that user
and oramid would have to also store a
separate data structure for each user so
we'll have to have a separate
pre-processed version of the internet
wherever user wants to make searches and
peer with contact speed process it's not
the case we just store the original data
but it would still have to do the linear
time work of of pre-processing engine
for that user and the user would store
some hint about the speed processing
so in contrast in our notion there's
just a one-time pre-processing that the
server does and can be used for all the
users can be reused for everyone in the
system
okay let's
so let me uh uh so okay how do we build
uh this notion this double f is appear
so let me start with kind of the the
construction template
uh of of how we do this
um and the idea is first we're just
going to construct a basic two round
here private information retrieval
without pre-processing and without
double efficiency so here the server
Works in linear time reads entire
database to answer every query
and uh well just give the protocol some
names so the query the the client sends
I'll call it Alpha and the responses
server sends I'll call that Beta And so
beta is some function that depends on
the database uh applied to the current
query Alpha this is just without loss of
generality I'm just getting the the
rounds and names
and so the second test is going to be
we're just going to take this function f
sub DB that the server has to compute
and try to pre-process it
into some data structure it allows the
server to compute it very efficiently
without reading the entire database
so those are the two steps but I didn't
really tell you anything this is like
you know the generic way you would want
to do it it doesn't really tell you a
hint about how we do it and maybe
uh you know the reason why
this has been hard to achieve in the
passes if you think about like the
service computation this function FDB
it's some complicated cryptographic
operations that the server has to do how
do you pre-process this function it's uh
I mean it seems unlikely or or hard to
imagine that you could pre-process some
you know this complicated cryptographic
operation so the first step is we're
gonna like try to contain step one a
little more try to make make it have a
nicer format and in particular we're
gonna come uh construct a peer scheme to
around here where the client query
consists of some small number of ring
elements in summary guard and the
service response the the service
computation is just evaluating some low
degree multivariate polynomial over the
contouring elements
so now it has some nice algebraic
structure
and then we're going to use this
beautiful result of kedlayan omans from
2008 which shows that you can
pre-process a multivariate polynomial
over some rings into some data structure
that allows for very fast evaluation
essentially to evaluate this polynomial
over in a future input you can do much
less work than reading all the
coefficients of the polynomial
okay so the first part really there's
some limits about what kind of peer we
can get what kind of ring what kind of
polynomials we can get that comes from
the cryptography and the second part
there's a lot of restrictions on what we
can
pre-processary process that comes from
the algorithm side so there's an
algorithms component and cryptography
component and a priori it's not clear
that they would like connect them nicely
there's a lot of restrictions from both
sides we found it quite surprising that
actually they like meet in the middle
and work together
[Music]
uh actually yeah both both kind of have
have a lot of flexibility but but still
still restricted but you know it's kind
of surprising they managed to meet in
the middle yeah
so in terms of the assumptions that you
have the restrictions on like what those
are mostly is coming from the algorithms
part right in terms of like or is it
kind of Photography what's coming uh
from making them meet together right so
the assumptions are to build uh uh uh
this this step one this this private
information stream over here that has
the right structure and the right kind
of parameters to pre-process using this
tool here so you really have to make the
meet
yeah
that's the size of the process structure
also enter the one or plus-ups yes
okay so let me actually start with the
second part because I think for the
cryptographers uh because if you haven't
seen this before it's made me more
surprising that you can process these
polynomials so I want to actually show
you this algorithm it's incredibly
simple it's it's in this beautiful paper
but it's kind of uh used to do more
complicated things and maybe it's hard
to like just get this basic God when it
just solves this this basic problem if
you actually look like under the hood
it's it's quite a simple algorithm so
here's dilemma we can take an M variate
polynomial over some rate R where the
individual degree of this polynomial is
at most uh D and we can pre-process it
into data structure that allows us to
very quickly evaluate the polynomial and
the future input
so first just I'll play the parameters
and second second first notice that uh
the the this polynomial if it's
individual degree D and M variate that
has D to the m coefficient so that's the
description size Capron will be the
description size of the polynomial
and here's the parameter so I don't
expect you to read it I'll simplify that
set but the pre-processing is linear
name but there's some additional factors
here
maybe in the main pack you should know
this is m to the m so this only works on
the number of variables it's pretty
small actually less than logarithmic
uh and then the valuation time okay it's
just this uh this expression let's
simplify it so we're going to pick uh
the variables this way we're going to
pick given like a a polynomial length
and which would also be the size of the
database later we're going to set the
degree to be like some big poly login
analog to C of n then we'll set the
number of variables so that you know
this is n so this will be the number of
variables and this will be the size of
the ring that will come from the
cryptography due to parallel again for
those who I'm hiding some security
parameter factors here
exactly right so this is very similar to
read molecule parameters and in that
case this pre-processing time becomes
just m to the one plus Epsilon and this
evaluation time becomes how they log n
so this is the set of cellular
parameters you can keep in mind
okay so let me prove uh oh and I should
say this doesn't work generally for all
ranks but it works for uh uh some nice
ranks namely it works for zq it works
for polynomial ranks even multivariate
polynomial rings and actually this will
be kind of the rents we'll need to get
okay so I'm not going to prove it for
General rings but I'll show you the
proof for just Zeke
okay so uh maybe to get some intuition
what are two ways of evaluing the
polynomial over zq one is to just just
keep the polynomial and then you know
you give me the the input I'll just like
about and read all the coefficients and
the value the main way another way of
pre-processing is I can just take every
possible input and write down the value
of the polynomial but that'll be like Q
to the m a size data structure which is
way too big we're we're thinking two
years already being superpowered
okay so we want to do something in
between something that has like small
data structure plus size evaluation
so the first step is actually to make
our life harder instead of thinking of
this uh function as a as a polynomial
over Z Cube we're just going to think of
doing the computation over the integers
without reducing math key
um okay but we'll still think of the
coefficients and inputs are in this
range zero to Q minus one so they're
relatively small
and then we can bound the output size of
this polynomial by this capital M which
is 2 to the power log n so the output
doesn't get too crazy because it's low
degree a few variables so this is the
this as an integer the output is not too
big
and now we're going to use the Chinese
remainder here
oh Q is 2
and so now we're gonna this is the main
idea is to use Chinese remainder theorem
so uh instead of evaluing the polynomial
integer IT Supplies this evaluated
modulo a bunch of small primes whose
product is bigger than the integer
output of the polynomial
and so we're going to just take all the
smallest primes the first uh evaluation
is fully
good yeah so we're going to think well
I'll tell you in a second yeah so we're
going to take all the smallest primes
less than 16 log M and it turns out that
we think the product is bigger than that
so we take few a small number of crimes
and they're relatively small each one of
these points less than 16. this question
is very naturally yeah
um okay so now we just need to evaluate
this polynomial module each of the small
primes so what do we do we reduce the
problem of a value in the polynomial due
to valuing a bunch of polynomials module
much much smaller Primes
uh you know we reduce some Q which is
like the super polynomial to Z to Pi
which is poly log if this is too big
which actually for us it will be uh you
can uh recurse again to make the price
even smaller
okay but now once the primes are really
small we can just pre-process these
polynomials by just valuing them at all
possible to the points all P to the end
points for whatever the small pranks yes
and this will be you know polyan
and if you you know do the comparis car
place we will adjust
okay and so then the evaluation is just
to look up uh these values in each of
the tables so look up the value of the
polynomial match of each of each of the
smaller SPI and then reconstruct using
Chinese remaining that's the entire idea
you
can also reduce the degree right
uh well right the degrees actually much
smaller already than the price but yeah
uh yeah
you're right the technique is never
bigger than the transcript yeah
and recursing makes sense I mean you're
gonna have the same primes show up again
and again but they're in like a
different context right and then mod
another crime so you know you don't need
to build more tables but you will need
to do the work of like reconstruction
reconstructing model like intermediate
level primes and then using Chinese
remaining to construction
so we just need like two levels uh one
recursive call two levels application so
you convert from like one polynomial to
login many polynomials mods like smaller
primes then you ignore the three small
primes again and they're going to have
some other coefficients if that matters
or not and then each of them also sort
of blows up to log something smaller so
you get like login Times log something
smaller total number of things and for
each one of them you pre-posited exactly
yeah
great so as you go down sort of the
vehicle size and working on is uh
smaller the degree overall across the
board
sometimes sometimes yeah yeah
so the field size goes down
um yeah at some point if it's like if
the parents are very small then the
degree you can kind of ignore it but
yeah
but is there is there like a not that
matters like an optimal belief like uh
how small can you make them if you right
because it's a trade-off right right so
this one level of recursion is it turns
out to be investment one thing is that
at each person calls you like make the
prime smaller but then you blow them up
by doing this trick so here the the M
gets bigger so it actually doesn't make
sense to do more than one level
okay so just this is the extension
Fields can use multiplication embeddings
yeah so that yeah so that's how you get
more complicated ranks and
um
but for example you can do polynomial
rings with this which is what we'll
actually need
so you cannot get better parameters
electricity is wasteful yeah
there are some tricks you can play to
optimize this uh yeah let me but just
again you need it to be over like a big
characteristic you can also say F2
extensions right
right so just yeah uh here
um
we'll actually do it over polynomial
ranks but we'll do it over yeah yeah but
you don't you don't need characters
there's no restriction on the characters
so even this data structure
exactly yeah
well I did tell you how to extend from
from CQ there are no mirrors but yeah
you can do it
because it's not going to gain what he
thinks that he's going to gain yeah I'm
not okay so I'm not trying to optimize
here but like you can do it for these
other rings as well kind of similar
Brothers it's just chicken once you can
make characteristic too yes I don't care
yeah you can be an engineer yeah there's
no it doesn't have to be proud
okay so uh good
um so that was the that was the
pre-processing so now let's talk about
how to construct this basic peer that
allows you where where the service
competition is just a value in
colonomial over some nice room
so uh the idea uh the reviews is to
actually just build maybe the most
intuitive kind of uh private information
retrieval from somewhat of a morphing
version someone of encryption means you
can compute some restricted functions
not all functions over the encrypted
data namely well one once we can compute
low degree polynomials so here's the
idea let's take the index that the user
has and write it down in some base D
which was said to be Prime and it'll
correspond also to the degree that we
saw in the previous slide so some fairly
small base
and uh let's uh let these just be the
digits uh in this base I'm just writing
down the the index I
and if I do that you can think of the
function that Maps this index to the if
location of the database you can
actually just interpolate a low degree
and variate polynomial that computes
this function
you can just write down the power number
okay so uh now uh okay so this
polynomial is in the picture well it's a
polynomial over ZD so degree doesn't
mean and the total degree is D times
number of variables
okay and so the client is just going to
choose a secret key and encrypt all of
these digits of the index
using some someone homework encryption
scheme and the server has to just
homomorphically evaluate this polynomial
over the ciphertext that's the server
computation
and then the client decrypts and gets
the gets the right value
so are we done can we apply the
pre-processing to this construction
uh well not really the problem is that
the service computation is not a value
in the pound on we have DB it's
homomorphically valuing the polynomial
DP over encrypted data and if you look
at kind of modern homorphic encryption
scheme the evaluation does a lot of
complicated things it's not just
polynomial batteries the multi-services
okay
so uh right so this the the server uh
has the homomorphically evaluate this
polynomial and who knows what the
homographic evaluation looks like
but actually turns out if you kind of
look at uh nice summer homework
encryption scheme actually not the
modern ones but you kind of take away
all the optimizations that matter
students do to become fully homomorphic
and go to the you know go back in time
and look at the early harmonic
encryption schemes they actually have a
nice structure that uh where the eval
would just be uh polynomial in fact it
would just be evaluating the same
polynomial DB over the ciphertext
so we give this a name we call this type
of homomorphic encryption algebraic
someone homework encryption it's kind of
the platonic ideal of what if homorphic
encryption should look like like if you
encrypt so the plaintext is some kind of
space CD if you encrypt messages in the
plaintext space you'll get ciphertext
which live in some ring R and then if
you add up the ciphertext you get an
encryption to send the messages if you
multiply separate types you get an
encryption of the product there's some
noise so you cannot do it too often but
as long as you do like few enough
operations this works
and so if f is some polynomial over ZD
and the total degree is not too big then
by just evaluating it same polynomial
over the ciphertax you have to lift it
to the ring R appropriately but by just
like lifting the polynomial to the
bigger ring and then evaluating over the
ciphertext you get an encryption of the
output of the polynomial on the
plaintext
okay and uh so I said there's some noise
and you can do too often but essentially
you can set the parameters such as if
your total degree of the polynomial is
capital D then the ciphertext size and
encryption decryption runtime are just
poly and D
and our capital D is going to be small
poly log n so
okay and so uh it turns out you can get
this type of algebraic someone on Murphy
encryption by uh making fairly light
modifications to Prior someone homework
encryption schemes for example the
Brokers scheme from ringgoldwe gives you
this uh or you can use entry or
approximate GCB
and so I'm not going to show it to you
but this is how we get uh the the basics
so this is the point just that the noise
doesn't become so big because you have a
down another degree and the ring is much
larger yes yeah so so that right so so
the ring kind of will grow with the
noise but our our polynomials are fairly
low that we probably won't get in fact
you could have handled like bigger
degree but just a nicer growth so we
don't even need to use it we need to use
these teams for a very very small degree
you can yeah yeah so we you can extend
it to get uh um like enter the OnePlus
little one at a cost of having bigger
than probably it's like a bigger than
probably a lot again online
okay so just to put it all together so
then that gives us the entire scheme
we're gonna first use this uh uh basic
here from someone homework from this
algebraic someone homework encryption uh
uh and then we notice that if we do that
then this developer the computation
server does is just evaluating the same
polynomial over the ciphertext over the
ring elements that the client sent so
now the scheme has the right structure
we're just going to take this polynomial
and pre-process it with Lionel mess and
that's the entire schema
so uh yeah let me mention uh about
updatable deep here uh so an updateable
DPA the server can update individual
bits of the database and correspondingly
update the preprocessed data structure
in sublinear time we can enter Epsilon
our basic construction is very much
non-localib data but you look at the
scheduling remote's construction every
bit of the data structure depends on
every bit of the database but we can
make it updatable using IDs from
hierarchical Oram
um maybe if there's extra Prime and then
like some size I can show them to you
but I'm going to skip that for now yeah
you can also extend the database
yeah you can also extend the database
you can add bits or or modify bits of
the database as well yeah
good
um
and this is actually generic you can
take any double efficient peer and
convert it into an updatable one as long
as the pre-processing time is small so
the update time will depend on the
pre-processing time or pre-processing
time was sent to the OnePlus Epsilon and
that gives us the update time of antilet
Epsilon
so here we really need to make sure like
that the pre-processing time is for
example less than N squared otherwise
you don't get it
it's in the same program
yeah yeah there's no secret State
there's not it's the the update is
completely like like deterministic but
the data structure for example depends
on what order things are updated it's
not like I cannot map it doesn't depend
just on the contents of the database but
also in which order it was absolute
history
so you can sort of start from an empty
database yeah
yeah yeah but you don't need to know the
size ahead of time
okay so uh now I want to tell you a
little bit about how to go from this
double efficient private information
retrievable totally home morphing
encryption
um in the ram model so first let me tell
you what the problem setting is so here
uh we have a server that has some
arbitrary value Y and think of it as a
big database it's not big a bit small
and we have a kind that has a private
input X and we want the client the user
to learn f of x y
uh without revealing extra servers so X
is the thing we're trying to keep hidden
so for example you can think of this as
Google search where why is the internet
and access the query or you can think of
it even as some Outsourcing computation
maybe why is empty and app is just some
very complicated computation server the
client wants a server to perform when
it's
so there's a trivial solution which is
the server sends y to the client and
tells the client to compute f of x y
themselves we don't like that for two
reasons maybe Y is too big so we don't
want to send y to the point we want to
save on the communication complexity but
also F may be very expensive expensive
to compute even if Y is small or Y is
empty uh we don't want to use the
solution because we want the server to
do the work of computing
okay so this is the problem that fully
homorphic encryption solves uh so
employee homework encryption this crime
just encrypts the input X sends it to
the server and the server builds a
circuit for the function f with Y
hard-coded inside
and just homomorphically value it's a
server over the client cycle text
to create an encryption CT star of the
of the output and then the coin just
decrypts the site protects when C of X
which is just a perfect slide
okay so this is fully homework
encryption
and in terms of communication time and
the client computation the client is
very happy based just on linear and the
input size and linear and output size
which is the best possible
uh but the server's runtime is
proportional to the Circuit size it's
when you're in the circuit size which
again we saw is generally not good right
for example in terms of Google search
that would be the size of the entire
at least it's linear in the size of Y
so this is this is something we want to
fix
and uh here we have constructions from
nice assumptions like learning with
errors or circular security if you want
to get the full notion
okay so uh to Define to pour the fhe to
the red model cut everywhere we had
circuit just change it to Ram program uh
okay so now we assume we have some Ram
program P for this function f and we'll
need to know some upper bound on the
runtime of this run program because the
server knows how long it runs and so
let's say we have some upper bound on
the runtime which will call capital t
and so now we want the service runtime
during this computation the servable
homomorphical value in this ramp program
over the encrypted production Decline
and this data Y and we want the service
runtime to be just of the proportional
to Ram runtime
so is it inherent like can I have input
specific running time or I have to run
in time T oh uh well the server would
learn how long it runs in so yeah
and that's not a problem but uh can it
like let's say that some computation
takes five steps and the sum takes five
thousand and five thousand yeah do I
need to run inside you uh you need to
set an upper bound ahead of time so
maybe you could try like if you have
backend First Communication you can do
better but with just this you will need
to know you could try running for two
steps sending back to a client and ask
am I done yet the client will say no you
try again for four steps eight steps you
know so you can do that but if it's not
interactive then uh we don't actually
know how to get it or you can just get
all power
so you can do binary search for example
yes yes so I wanted to T can be much
more than this is the ram model so yeah
it can be much smaller than one
uh good so uh but this notion okay my
full view this is impossible uh for the
same reason double efficiency was
impossible because the server sees which
locations of why it touches it would
learn something about the computation
which would reveal something about X so
uh to fix that we again need to add
pre-processing so before the difference
computation start the server has to
pre-process this public input Y into
some data structure why tell that and
then it will use this data structure why
tell that to execute the computation
and the pre-processing time ideally
would be just linear and why okay we
don't quite get this we get someone plus
Epsilon factors everywhere
that's it okay so yeah to answer uh
amir's question so I'm thinking of the
ram program p as having Ram access to
everything you can have Ram access to
the input y
which is kind of useful for let's say
Google Search right uh so their X is
small but you want you want to you don't
want to read the entire internet
uh but I'm also allowing the program to
have Ram access to the input X it
doesn't have to do linear scan so maybe
X is an encrypted data beta and you want
to do some queries over this encrypted
database that the client Outsource
system server and in addition the
program P could have some additional
read write memory so this would be
useful if like Y is empty and you want
to just Outsource Ram computation in
general to convert from Ram to Circuit
you have to pay at least linear input
size plus quadratic in the runtime so
here you would avoid this quadratic cost
okay so there's a very long ram access
to everything
[Music]
yeah so we we have all kinds of
extensions you can like uh you can do
multi-hop multi-input so for example
like you can take the outputs of some
computation users inputs the future
computation uh uh pretty much everything
you can think of is allowed so does this
give you like a generic solution for the
datable W efficient peer if you allowed
right yes but this I mean this uses that
to solve the problem so right you need
that you need updated
okay so let me just say about prior work
so in a paper from 2019 we showed uh we
gave the first evidence of this type of
ram FH is possible actually we construct
a slightly weaker variant of ram fhc
there was no server input Y which is Ram
access to the encrypted data X
so didn't for example allow this like
Google Search application but we did it
from Pete double efficient peer so key
double efficiency already used this vbb
obfuscation inside at least at that time
that's still in the construction yeah
but we didn't we couldn't that wasn't
enough we needed to like use additional
vbb office station to then generically
convert from Deep here to this notion
so uh so in this work we just showed
that you how to do this from ringgelwe
well plus circular security just because
even standards FHA in the circuit model
needs circuit security if you don't have
circular security you get something weak
or some level of motion
okay so uh so I said that we want to do
this for programs that Ram access to
everything XY read write memory uh I
want to show you a simpler case where
the program has only a ram access to the
public input y but not to X or to any
additional lead right now
okay so here's how I want to think of
the computation I'm thinking about as a
bunch of CPU steps each CPU has some
fairly small like circuit description
with some small amount of registers
initial then put X is going to be just
written on the registers and each step
of the computation like evaluates this
kind of one CPU step circuit uh updates
the state the registers and asks to read
an index in the data y
and then on the next step you magically
get the output of the of the data uh
so this is just a general way of writing
the the Duram computation as a sequence
of these small circuit steps
okay so the idea is let's use circuit
fhe to do the computation so first we're
going to encrypt X under just our fhe
circuit fhc scheme and then we're going
to evaluate these CPU circuits one by
one
so when you evaluate the spur CPU
circuit you get an encryption of the
State plus an encryption of the index
that you want to look up in the database
so now on the next step I want to get an
FH encryption of the value in the in the
assign the memory or yeah and the data Y
at that index but how do I do that
so how do we access y uh in this
computation so it seems clear we should
somehow use double efficient peer that's
the two we have at our exposal we need
to hide this location I but still access
the identification of the database but
who makes the peer queries I mean this
there's no client to make these queries
there's just this computation the server
is running on its side
and so the main idea is that actually
our double our DPS scheme has a nice
structure where we can nicely convert
between fhe ciphertext and DPR queries
and DPR answers back to fhc ciphertext
so kind of this encryption of I that we
get during the computation we can
actually translate it into DPF query for
I answer it using the DPS team and then
translate the answer back into an fhe
ciphertext that we can then continue
running the computational
and the idea is that actually we can
build an encryption scheme that's the
best of both worlds it's simultaneously
and algebraic somewhat homework
encryption scheme which is the
encryption scheme we use to make peer
queries the DPA queries and an fhe that
lets you compute arbitrary circuits and
they get kind of the best advantages in
both worlds so as an SAT scheme if you
have one evaluate low degree polynomials
which is what we needed for the DPR
queries you can do this with nice
algebraic structure you just evaluate
the polynomial the cipher types you
don't need to do anything complicated
but this only lets you evaluate more
degree column it's not much
but then you can also use it as an
Apache where you evaluate arbitrary
circuits but this doesn't this uses like
crazy up you know there's all kinds of
non-algebraic stuff uses bit
decomposition so this doesn't have any
nice structure but you can do it and
moreover you can go back and forth
between these so if you get an output of
the fhe you can translate it back into
the Ashe and you can think of an sag
protection translate back into
FHA without knowing the security yeah
you can just translate back and forth
between these two schemes so can you do
generically with uh so you can translate
to generically but translating from
fhe to Ashe you need to evaluate yeah
you need to Value the decryption so we
actually yeah we actually by using
Capital page it's actually the Apache Cy
protects already ASAP you know makes it
nice it's not completely generic but
close enough in your scheme is there
actually a switch or is the ciphertext
just like get the transformation it's
identical it's doing something in One
Direction so when you translate
from Ashe to fhe like after sat in the
second text it's quite different and
then to translate to FH you need to do
some bootstrapping so then the fhe Tosh
so it's just a description algorithm two
different descriptions well you can you
can always translate to one one of these
two and have that be the description
that doesn't really matter
yeah
so it's kind of one scheme but I I think
of it as one scene that lets you do both
types of operations like uh low degree
polynomials very easily by a very nice
homorphic evaluation procedure or
general circuits by a non-license
I think that they used in like these uh
sort of practical-ish fhe like tfhe
right this is sort of the sort of tricks
that uh I think so yeah this is like
this type of idea that you can switching
between fhg encryptions is something
that's like uh been done a lot
so we can do this from ringgelw or does
assumptions
so then uh uh the whole evaluation has
this nice structure where you just start
with the encryption of X kind of run the
computation get the FH encryption so
everything's happening under fhg
encryption get the encrypted index and
the next state then you translate this
encrypted index into an ash encryption
of the index but that's just a deep your
crate for an index so now use the DPR to
answer it uh and translate that into an
fhe encryption of the output and then
continue the computation
so that that's what gives you Ram fhe uh
okay this only gave you this restricted
notion where you only had Ram access to
Y but not to X and there was no read
write memory to get Random Access text
it's actually very similar it's quite
easy you can do the same thing the idea
is that when the cons encrypted X the
current already has to scan all of X in
linear time to encrypt it it's also
going to apply this DP or pre-processing
of extra while we're at access tax
so that's fairly easy to do random
access memory is a little more tricky
but we're essentially going to use some
sort of an updatable deep here to keep
track of working memory during the
computation
so uh well updatable DP was talking
about public memory so here we're going
to ask you to like use an encrypted
version of memory with updatable deep
here to handle this but it can be done
okay so that's uh pretty much what I
wanted to say uh let me just conclude so
we construct both DP and apigee for amps
from ring lwe and there's a lot of nice
looking questions left so for example
can we do it from plain LW very much
everything in the past we've had from
ringgoldwe like within less than a year
we've had a way of doing it from plain
lwe so clock is ticking uh let's do it
for for uh
so here it seems like the main hurdle is
the algorithm theme right yes yeah right
so so there seems to be uh yeah the
difficulties that the algorithm Works
only for specific rings and requires a
lot of structure so uh seems to be a
little harder but I think that's the
thing to size I mean that's uh yeah
that's that's right
so for example if you had a way of
pre-processing polynomials over matrices
uh you would be able to solve this
problem nicely but I don't know how to
do that
um the other question is practical
efficiency this construction doesn't use
like any
haven't had this there's no obfuscation
there's there's nothing insane going on
here but still I think uh practically be
quite an efficient if you like did
everything naively the way I described
uh the Republic
yeah it's kind of the combination of
everything it's the farmers you get from
fhe combined with the pre-processing
multi yeah exactly so I think but I
think there's a lot of room for
optimization that there's all types of
blend algorithm both and and optimizing
fhc schemes you use so I think there's a
lot of Hope here to actually make this
practical admission
and heuristic construction no actually I
don't yeah
for example
from depth between the
employee support no even if you use the
best like like the the you know
because of the problems I don't think so
no I mean people have instantiated with
the most aggressive parameters already
so we can just take that aggressive
choice but it's more about the
pre-processing and the power
um yeah I think there's a lot of room
for improvement
and uh there are a lot of obvious
applications uh you know anywhere you
want to use fhe or peer now replace this
but uh I think it'd be interesting also
to find kind of applications for that
field it's a new primitive and I think
it should have other uses that uh that
are not the obvious obvious uses
definitely efficient peer you translate
each database query you can always
operate queries
under security parameter factors so it
should be a security parameter uh it
should be a secure parameter in there
you need to have a high entropy of like
where a specific index how many
different queries there are for one
index so we need at least
[Music]
uh yeah actually so maybe you said I
missed it where do you use the sort of
o-ram inspired techniques this is to do
the right in a doubly efficient period
yeah yeah so I mean I uh let's see I
have some slides on it it's not in the
sort of uh going from doubly efficient
peer to the no no it's still in the
double efficient we are setting so
essentially like you you keep the ideas
you you'll like store your your data
structure which consists of many levels
each one is pre-processor deep here
whenever you write you write to the top
level pre-process it and you somehow
every once in a while you merge the top
bunch of levels and reprocesses
the server is still deterministic every
time it's right right it's completely
determistic but the data structure is
now history different and where the data
resides on which level depends on uh
when it was written so you don't need
like the amortized like the way
what kind of what kind of Orem
the query time is the same you actually
query every level with deep here so the
query time is just like logarithmically
bigger than the originals but the update
time depends on the pre-processing so
every bunch of times I merge a bunch of
levels and we pre-process but so the
other time is amortized or it's um good
it's amortized in the basic scene but
you can advertise it like there's
there's these standard tricks but since
I saw this slide yeah yeah there's
standard tricks and the amortized
any more questions okay thank you
great to be here at 10 30.